La función "f" de "x" es graficada;
¿cuál es su dominio?
Viendo la manera en la que esta graficada aquí,
podemos asumir que ésta muestra la definición completa de la función "f" de "x",
por ejemplo
si decimos, a qué es igual "f" de "x"
cuando "x" es igual a -9.
Vemos que si vamos por aquí arriba,
no vemos su gráfica aquí,
no está definida para "x" igual a -9,
o "x" igual a -8 y medio
o x igual a -8,
no está definida
para ninguno de estos valores.
Empieza a definirse cuando "x" es igual a -6,
en "x" igual a -6,
"f" es igual a 5,
pero continúa estando definida.
"f" de "x" está definida para "x" en todo el intervalo,
desde -6 hasta el 7 positivo.
Cuando "x" es igual a 7
"f" de "x" es igual a 5,
puedes tomar
cualquier valor de "x" entre -6
incluyendo el -6 y 7 positivo...
incluyendo el 7 positivo,
y solo tienes que moverte hacia arriba de este número,
desde donde estés,
para saber cuál es el valor de la función
en este punto.
Entonces el dominio de ésta,
de esta función definida,
bueno
"f" de "x" está definida para toda "x"
que sea igual o mayor a -6,
o podemos decir que -6,
es igual o menor que "x",
que es menor o igual a 7.
Si "x" satisface esta condición, la función está definida,
por lo que éste es su dominio
así que verifiquemos nuestra respuesta.
Hagamos unos cuantos más de estos.
La función "f" de "x" está graficada,
¿cuál es su dominio?
Tenemos un argumento similar,
esta función no está definida
para valores de "x"
-9, -8...
hasta el -1...
en menos uno empieza a definirse,
"f" de -1 es -5.
Así que la función está definida,
cuando -1 es menor o igual a "x".
Está definida desde ahí hasta "x" igual a 7,
incluyendo "x" igual a 7,
entonces esto de aquí es -1,
menor o igual a "x",
"x" menor o igual a 7.
La función está definida para cualquier "x",
que satisfaga esta doble desigualdad de aquí.
Hagamos más ejemplos,
la función "f" de "x" es graficada;
¿cuál es su rango?
Ahora no estamos pensando en los valores de "x",
en los que está definida la función,
estamos pensando en el conjunto de valores de "y"
lo que es donde...
donde caen todos los valores de "y".
Vamos a ver,
el menor valor posible de "y",
o el menor valor posible de "f" de "x"
que podemos obtener aquí
parece ser que es 0,
la función nunca va más abajo de 0.
Entonces
"f" de "x" es 0,
que es menor o igual que "f" de "x"
de hecho si llega a ser igual a 0,
justo aquí,
donde "f" de "x" valuada en -4 es 0,
y el valor más grande de "y",
el valor más grande que "f" de "x" obtiene
en esta definición de función es 8.
"f" de 7 es 8
y nunca se vuelve más grande que 8,
pero si es igual a 8,
justo aquí cuando "x" es igual a 7.
Entonces 0 es menos o igual a "f" de "x",
la que es menor o igual a 8,
por lo que ese es su rango.
Hagamos uno más.
Esto es algo divertido.
La función de "f" de "x" es graficada,
¿cuál es su dominio?
Nuevamente esta función está definida
cuando -2...
-2 es menor o igual a "x",
que es menor o igual a 5.
Si me das una "x" en cualquier lugar,
entre -2 y 5
puedo ver esta gráfica
para ver cómo está definida esta función.
"f" de -2 es -4,
"f" de -1 es -3,
y así sucesivamente,
puedo escoger valores entre estos enteros.
Así que -2 es menor o igual a "x",
que es menor o igual a 5.